joining me now is serial entrepreneur
shark tank star and chairman of oh
shares etfs the one and only kevin
o'leary mr wonderful wonderful to have
you back with us
great to be here thank you so much
all right so kevin jamie dimon is saying
that regulators are quote going to
regulate the hell out of bitcoin now you
told me last time you were with us that
regulation is in fact a positive that it
creates clarity
allowing more institutional investors to
come in but you got gary gensler calling
the space the wild west you have the
infrastructure bill crammed with what
many have called oppressive regulation
so are you concerned that the crypto
space could become over-regulated and
over-taxed
well it tells you that there's so much
activity from all of these different
players first of all i'm a huge jamie
diamond fan and a shareholder of
jpmorgan as well and i listened to his
comments regarding this i for one would
welcome the regulator uh to come in here
and start to apply regulate regulatory
platforms to all of these crypto uh
currencies and all of the level one and
level two chain block chains because
in order
you've got to understand something
people are very excited about crypto but
but the truth is
the real money the institutional money
is not there yet so the majority of
bitcoin is held by individuals or hedge
funds or high net worth individuals or
family offices in the domestic market
but i you know i work closely with lots
of pension plans and sovereign funds
they're not touching any of this yet for
one singular reason the regulator has
not ruled and secondly there's no
infrastructure to actually be compliant
and so
the reason you would want to take a
position in this is
you see the long-term opportunity of
saving costs being more efficient more
transparent faster all of these things
can be provided by cryptocurrencies and
the blockchain this is great technical
innovation
but you you don't have a regulator
that's made a decision yet so
in some ways you know jamie dimon's
right we should get it regulated but
that's also why i'm a shareholder
because in in cryptocurrencies because
when the regulator does finally resolve
this issue
there's going to be a huge amount of
capital that's been sitting on the
sidelines coming in to take allocations
from the institutional perspective and
that i'm pretty excited about
and yes to your point as you've said
before regulation creates clarity opens
up the door to institutional investors
but is there a point
of perhaps over regulation are you no
longer concerned about a big existential
crisis
that the u.s follows china's lead and it
becomes outlawed is that still an issue
or is that an existential threat
that for the most part people are now
dismissing at least regarding bitcoin
yeah it's a good it's a great point and
you're raising a very good question but
you have to think about the way the
american economy has developed versus
the chinese centrally regulated economy
the innovation and today in the world
the us economy is still the largest most
productive economy
is because we embrace innovation
cryptocurrencies blockchain
uh you know all of this is technical
innovation and provides productivity
enhancement and also reducing fees the
largest market on earth is the currency
market there's just one use case i'd
point to you and say that when i want to
buy a stock in swiss francs or in euro
or in british pounds or in you know any
other country and be on that domestic
exchange i have to go through the whole
fx currency traders platform where i pay
fees left and right over time as
regulators adopt payment systems that
are you know regulated and approved by
regulators in multiple geographies those
costs and that transparency and that
block ledger is going to be far more
efficient than anything we're doing
right now and i think even even the sec
realizes that and knows that this is
innovation and it requires a good study
before they actually rule on it but i
don't think we're going to be like china
where um the great leader or whatever
you want to call him decides personally
he doesn't like how many hours your kids
are watching videos or whether or not
blockchain has merit as a productivity
tool
that's not the way the american economy
works so i'm making the assumption that
you just have to wait until the regular
makes their movement and there's so many
different use cases that are look so so
much great potential that why wouldn't i
be an investor why wouldn't i place some
bets with a diversified portfolio of
cryptocurrencies and level one and level
two blockchains
okay so regulation you are still seeing
as a positive and you don't think that
there is this big existential threat of
it being outlawed
last time we spoke you correctly
identified the issue of esg since then
there's actually been a big shift to use
clean energy in fact mining operations
are actually facilitating the creation
of more and more clean energy resources
we've got the bitcoin mining council
there's certainly been a shift
especially with china banning it more
mining activity moving to north america
and europe so where are you on the esg
issue do you think that that is being
addressed sufficiently well at this
point
well you know i don't have a crystal
ball on those issues i simply listen to
institutional investors they off the
record tell me what they're thinking and
they brought up the esg issue two years
ago saying they have esg committees they
have sustainability committees that look
at every asset class including crypto
including bitcoin and at that time there
are lots of people burning coal to
create electricity in various
geographies around the world to mine
bitcoin that's simply not sustainable it
doesn't work and they didn't want all
those coins the initiative now to solve
that problem and to bring in that huge
amount of institutional capital is
available to invest in just let's talk
about bitcoin the granddaddy of all
cryptocurrencies is to set up operations
in places like west texas where you can
do it with wind and solar and also
provide extra electricity to the grid
when you're not using it all for mining
and so there's lots of potential there
there's lots of capital being raised to
do that and those coins for these miners
are going to be held sequestered they're
going to be awarded using these clean
ways of of mining them and they'll be
owned by the institutions that have
these sustainability mandates so they'll
know the origin and the date of award
and they'll know that it was done
sustainably and they're happy to hold it
what people need to understand is most
institutions don't consider bitcoin a
trading vehicle they consider it as
property they think it's just like a
building going up in value over time and
that's the majority of concern around
sustainability so if they can buy the
coin mine sustainably and just hold on
to it know with certainty the origin of
that individual coin problem solved and
believe me there's lots of capital
trying to solve that problem right now
and i'm part of it so do you think that
there's going to be two asset classes of
bitcoin uh those that were mined
previously using uh unsustainable
energy and those that have been mined
using clean energy do you see a
bifurcation in the classes of bitcoin
going forward
there was an attempt to do that and put
a wrap around bitcoin but that was
rejected because we need fungibility we
can't have two classes because you could
argue that one class would be worth more
than the other and it causes confusion
if you consider it a simple asset so
there's going to be two classes of
owners of bitcoin those that don't care
about sustainability and i'm not one of
those and those that are mining their
own coin getting it awarded in
sustainable ways and there's a third way
to play it you can find the equities of
public miners that only mine sustainably
that keep their coin on their balance
sheet and own the shares you'll find
that they trade in the same volatile
fashion as bitcoin does hud 8 h.u.t on
nasdaq is a good example i'm a
shareholder of that company and it's
very correlated to the price of bitcoin
so i have exposure that way too and the
ceo there has a mandate to number one
maintain ownership of the coin on her
balance sheet jamie leverton is her name
and number two mine sustainably that's
her mandate that's what she wants to do
this is a really good company run by a
very uh good manager and a woman that
understands what institutions want
well let's let's go beyond uh if we're
gonna go macro let's go beyond bitcoin
because people think that the only way
you can invest in crypto is owning
bitcoin or ethereum the truth is there's
so much activity going on so much
research so much development going on in
other areas of decentralized finance
that there's huge opportunities beyond
just bitcoin so the way i look at it the
best way and this is a personal
interpretation i'm not saying that you
know any of the indexes have decided
this yet but i'm now viewing
cryptocurrencies and decentralized
finance so-called defy as the 12th
sector of the s p nobody's decreed that
yet but i'm doing it in terms of how i
manage my own operating portfolio and
the operating company so in in my view
of the world in investing
i look at never owning more than 20
percent in any one sector currently 11
sectors including real estate in the s p
500 and never owning more than five
percent of any one name in any sector so
when i put my i wrap my head around
those mandates that i are self-imposed
and how we operate we make sure that we
think of crypto that same way so we
don't want to just own bitcoin we do but
i but i also own ethereum eth i also own
solona i also own um all kinds of other
blockchains level one level two and what
i've decided to do because i get
bombarded with questions about what i
own outside of bitcoin i formed a
relationship with ftx as you may be
aware i'm a paid spokesperson for them
and also a shareholder now in the ftx
private company because i wanted a a a
platform that could
actually hold my interest in a compliant
level compliant basis with compliant
infrastructure so i can report it to my
own internal officers for compliance and
my external
auditors that can then of course sign
off on my statements that i have to
provide to regulators and the tax
authorities and everything else ftx was
big enough to do that so i'm using them
but in i don't want to ever be seen as
someone who finds some collecting
there's 12 000 coins out there and you
see this happening on the internet all
the time somebody starts promoting a
coin that no one's ever heard of i don't
want to be involved in any of that so
i'm just going to disclose my holdings
you understand kind of the way i look at
it no more than 20 currently i'm on
target to get to 7
in cryptocurrencies and crypto tokens
and crypto level one level two chains by
the end of december and then i'm simply
going to disclose what i own and you
know hopefully we can have an
intelligent conversation about why and
what i own but i'm certainly not going
to be flipping and trading and day
trading and all that stuff so if you've
expanded uh the crypto sector to seven
percent of your overall allocation and
you're seeing crypto as another sector
as you mentioned
can you break down for me the most
prominent positions that you have within
the crypto sector
well i i i can but i won't do it yet
because i'm still amassing positions
which is why i'm saying sometime towards
the end of the year you and i'll have
this conversation again and i'll
disclose the percentage holdings of
everything i've got but i must tell you
it's broadening out every day and i'm
including the equities of companies that
are 100 engaged in the crypto business
so i'm trying to get as diversified as i
can get and you've got to remember when
you when you go past five percent
waiting which i've i'm on my way to go
past you have to have a stomach for
volatility i mean you know we get lots
of volatility in these names i don't
care whether you want bitcoin or
ethereum or anything else the vol is is
really really uh heavy and i'll tell you
why it's because there's no
institutional support that's why that's
why it's such a benefit if we could ever
open this up get the regulator on board
and get one or two or three percent
allegation into cryptocurrencies within
the sovereign and pension plans it would
reduce volatility in an incredible way
but we're not there yet and we're
probably a couple of years away at the
earliest well i know one of the ways
that you are playing the sector at large
is through your one defy app tapping
into the d5 interest that's launching
very soon i believe tell us a little bit
about that kevin
yeah so the investment there is is an
attempt to
simplify decentralized finance and i
always use this use case as an example
um
you know about 18 months ago i started
divesting out of our operating companies
holdings in commercial real estate for
various reasons and it's been a great
long-term hold and it generated a lot of
cash and so when we went to the cash
desk markets
and started trying to deploy this cash
on a short-term basis we were getting
offers like 21 basis points now 21 basis
points does not beat inflation when
inflation's over 2
so i had a real problem there i thought
my goodness i can't lose 2 percent of
buying power over the next 12 months
i've got to find a solution so that
motivated me to go into the
the the stable coin market and so let's
take a you know something like usdc or
die these are
the concept there and i know the
regulator is very active right now in
stable coins but the concept is it's
backed by something uh like the u.s
dollar in just like a money market fund
could conceptually be thought of to be
backed by you know short-term treasuries
et cetera and there's been a lot of
controversy so i'm not saying it's the
same but the idea is if you take us
dollars that you're making 21 basis
points on and you buy usdc for an
example and then you stake it in other
words you loan it out for a 30 60 90 day
contract period
you can get paid back in a form of
interest i don't want to call it
interest but you might get 3.8 to 5.2
percent paid back in usdc which is a
stable coin then you can convert that
back into us dollars this is not risk
i'm not saying it is but i decided to
want i decided to do that with a portion
of our cash in our operating company
to get that set up and this is a long
answer to the wonderful you know
question you asked me but i want to
bring out the basis upon why i invested
in wonderful
it took me six months to get that set up
i had to hire three new people inside of
my organization just to manage that
process and be compliant at the same
time
now nobody is going to do what i did if
they have fourteen thousand dollars in
their bank account it's just not worth
it it's so complicated
so really what wonderful is an attempt
to simplify that just there's one
example of what wonderful hopefully will
do
in a use case where you could get some
interest off your cash holdings in a
decentralized platform and the whole
idea is to make it easy for people to be
compliant to be able to do it simply so
it's not that complicated and be
compliant with the tax authorities with
the reporting requirements they need for
each geography that they're doing that
in that is the essence of wonderful
simplification commoditization and
bringing the opportunities to a much
wider base of people that certainly
wouldn't go through what i went through
to set this up within our operating
company now i get it the opportunity is
there but to your point it's very
complicated but i want to circle back to
regulation
and i'm using circle intentionally
because of your partnership with circle
and as you mentioned yellen really has
stable coins in her crosshairs
particularly keen to target regulations
of usdc
gensler's calling stable coins the poker
chips in the crypto casino sec is
currently putting together a report
specifically about stable coins so where
do you see that taking the whole world
of d5 how do you see that impacting your
d5 venture
well i'm very happy she's brought this
up i'm very happy if letters looking at
it i want them to i want them to rule on
this we know that you know they're
engaged in a conversation with circle
circle was the creator and is back in
usdc there's over 30 billion dollars of
of usdc out there now so this is not
going away and and the point is it's a
very very efficient payment system usdc
so i'm sure the regulator sees the
benefit of of harnessing this
opportunity and working with circle and
i'm speculating on how the outcome is
going to occur but i'm willing you know
i don't have all of my cash in usdc i
have an allocation of it but i'm a
believer in what they're trying to do
and you know i've also
looked at it as an investment
opportunity they're currently in a
despacking process if if it happens i'll
happy to be buy some of the pipe of of
you know what they're going to be doing
and and my attitude about all this is we
should welcome the regulator we really
should because in my view it should be
regulated the same way a money market
fund is you know you never want the
money market fund to break a buck you
don't want to run on the bank there's
there's risks in everything but i love
the idea that the regulator is going to
really
you know but when they regulate it
they're basically voting as a real asset
class provided they don't regulate it
out of existence and i guess that's my
big question you're not concerned that
they won't come in and say no more
stable coins
um they could but i think the cat's out
of the bag i think the genies out of the
bottle and all those other ways of
looking at it because the productivity
enhancement proven already in the first
30 billion the opportunity to be the
leaders in this worldwide the
opportunity to enhance the productivity
of our own economy and payment systems
and all of the other things that stable
coins could do
are are just
too
big an opportunity for an economy the
size of and i just don't think the
regulator is going to say no no no no we
don't want any of that innovation we
don't want any of that enhancement to
productivity we don't want to cut fees
in in payment systems we don't want to
be more liquid more transparent on the
blockchain it doesn't make intuitive
sense that that would happen it does
make intuitive sense it would be
regulated when that occurs much more
money will come into it so i'm willing
to take a chance with that and put some
dollars on the line as i have done
all right well we're waiting for the sec
report on stablecoins for clarity there
and speaking of reports
the fed is planning to launch its review
on issuing a cbdc a us digital currency
the fed version or fedcoin would be
issued by the fed and officials are
divided on the matter we chatted about
this last time how the people's bank of
china
first to the party here
some in the fed think that this has to
happen for the u.s to stay in the lead
to stay relevant given the status of the
dollar as a dominant currency in
international payments
powell has been a little bit more
hesitant some major privacy concerns
he says it can't happen without
congressional approval but kevin do you
think
that this fat coin idea is going to
happen
and do you think it should happen
this is again a personal opinion i think
you and i will be still talking about
this 20 years from now as far as the the
fed doing that i think what's more
likely to happen is that they will uh
basically regulate uh issuers of stable
coins as banks and so you you look at a
circle they'll get a bank license
they'll be regulated uh as a and and so
if they're tying their stable coin to
the us dollar then they you know one
argument from the from the regulator's
point of view would be well let's treat
it like a bank through all the
regulatory environments the banks have
to deal with and and all of the balance
sheet you know scrutiny and everything
else and that would be a good outcome i
mean you know i'd be okay with that too
the idea that the fed itself issues its
own um
you know uh
stable coin i i actually don't think
they're set up to do that they don't
have the infrastructure yet doesn't mean
they couldn't do it why wouldn't they
just take out one of the existing issues
of stable coin that's already done all
the work and has built up you know a
large
following that could be another path but
to me
you want the market to be the market on
innovation these innovations came from
the private markets to solve for really
big problems in financial services
that's not what the fed does the fed is
not an entrepreneurial innovation engine
it's essentially a regulator and i think
be the best regulator you can be and be
the best innovator you can be and put
them in the same same economy and then
you get the economy of the united states
of america i think we're going to leave
that alone to be and let it continue to
work that way the the amount of
innovation and the deals that i'm seeing
now and all the ideas that are coming
down to decentralized finance
i never expect the government to deliver
that i expect you know somebody sitting
in a basement dreaming that up looking
at sam bankman freed a 29 year old 20
you know multi-billionaire who who
dreamt up ftx as a global platform and
he delivered it we need that kind of
innovation in our economy to keep it
cutting edge and leading the globe in in
these kinds of productivity tools
what about the argument that the fed has
to follow the people's bank of china's
lead that they've now taken the step
and in order to keep up the fed has to
do it whether it's in its mandate to do
it or not there needs to be that
movement you don't think that that's a
concern
well i don't think we have to worry
about uh china's
uh version of its stable coin what
person outside of china would ever put
that on their balance sheet that thing
as far as i'm concerned is toxic waste i
wouldn't touch it and so i would never
appeal any value to it i don't like
having the ch
a single individual in a foreign
government deciding who can own it who
cannot and having a track on it because
that blockchain is going to let them
know that i own it no thanks and so i'm
just one investor the chance they
convince global investors to buy that
zero
okay well i think many people find that
very reassuring because the idea
of a digital dollar and what it means
for privacy is very disconcerting to
many people so i'm i for one am pretty
reassured by the fact that you don't
think it's happening in in my lifetime
but this whole idea about uh currencies
it's stemming back to this concern
about lack of faith in the u.s dollar
we've got citadel's ken griffith
slamming cryptocurrencies and i quote as
a jihadist call against the dollar he's
saying that it shows that we don't
believe in the dollar and and i'm
quoting it's a crazy concept that we as
a country embrace so many bright young
talented people to come up with a
replacement for our own reserve currency
do you see it that way
no you know the big decision you have to
make and i appreciate every voice in the
debate and i i encourage it
having a free market of discussion of
ideas enhances productivity and none of
and not everybody agrees with each other
particularly when it comes to a new
innovation like cryptocurrencies
and as an investor you have to take this
decision path
do i want to invest in cryptocurrencies
yes or no and so that's decision number
one if you're you know if you don't like
them for whatever reason then the answer
is no you don't have to worry about it
anymore if the answer is yes you have to
decide what percentage of my operating
portfolio i'm going to put into this
very volatile nascent asset class and
and what will i hold and why will i hold
it that requires more work more research
but the concept of debasing the us
dollar because there's cryptocurrencies
i don't believe that at all we just
talked about stable coins and how
important it is that there be some of
them tied to the u.s dollar that gives
you the confidence to own them as even
as the regulators determining what the
ratio should be of leverage and
everything else or whatever else they're
going to decide to do with it because
that's the same regulation they put on
money market funds which are based
around the strength of the us dollar
short-term treasuries short-term
investment grade credits bank loans all
the rest of that stuff
this this already exists the best way i
look at it is say this already exists as
a format we're just changing it into a
digital format to be more efficient more
transparent and certainly more liquid
and less and less fees involved and so
i'm confident that this will get worked
out but i am not in that camp remember
i'm a convert i was against this back in
2017 and i've changed my mind because
things have changed around me and i have
to be listening i've got to have my ear
to the track i got to see what's coming
digital currencies
decentralized finance is not going away
it's here to stay now get over it if
you're somebody that's not an advocate
and figure out where you fit in that
continuum
well i for one certainly applaud you for
being bold enough to say look i've
looked at the facts again and i've
changed my mind a lot of people get too
stuck in ego to reverse positions but as
you say you have reevaluated the
situation and ideologically you're on
board but i want to get back to this
idea of dollar debasement because much
of the interest in cryptos and bitcoin
is fueled by this idea of dollar
debasement and unprecedented stimulus
we've got the debt ceiling deadline
approaching yellen is saying that it's
going to be catastrophic if the u.s
doesn't raise the debt ceiling by
october 18th and pay its bills she's
predicting a recession amongst other
consequences
are you concerned about the fundamentals
of the us economy regardless of whether
they managed to pull something off by
october 18th are the fundamentals of the
u.s economy sufficiently strong enough
when you look at this post coded
mmt influenced environment
you know i have an advantage in some
ways i have investments in over 30
private companies in almost every sector
and so i get to see the tear sheets
monthly and sometimes weekly on cash
flows and and sales
i we're having the best operating year
ever i have never seen such strength at
the consumer level it's remarkable um
it's like coming out in the late 50s an
explosion after the second world war you
know really strong single-digit gdp
growth right in the quarter in right now
i anticipate um getting better actually
uh as we get out of this covid the delta
uh you know issue i i'm very confident
the american consumer is in a great
place
um and i and i just look at it for my
own businesses so i'm not worried about
the economy the debasement of the
currency the this this movie that's
playing out again in washington we've
all seen this movie before i mean it's
very divisive now they're they're not
going to let the the country go into
default everybody knows that's but
that's why the market doesn't care all
today instead of working on that problem
they're facebook bashing you know it's
if they can't get the infrastructure
bill um
passed washington is very dysfunctional
but everybody knows that and so
yes it's a lot of noise but it's not
it's not going to play out that way
we're going to get the last minute
decision thank goodness those
politicians stayed awake until 1201 and
signed it oh my goodness disaster has
been avoided it's it's all a passion
play that just is getting really
tiresome and boring and i'm just one you
know taxpayer complaining about it it's
it's almost getting monty python lake
and i wish they they could get their
their poop together and just get it done
it would be much much better because
it's tiring and it's stupid and it's
it's unnecessary and everybody knows how
it's going to end well hopefully
hopefully it does repeat the same plot
as we've seen in dozens of movies before
and we'll have the countdown clock and
in the nick of time congress manages to
pull something together
but again it is pointing to the divisive
environment
in washington which is divisive across
the country
uh ray dalio for one says that that's
one of his biggest concerns that he's
concerned that the societal tensions
may spark some kind of civil war perhaps
not in the sense of guns and rifles and
cannon civil war but he's very concerned
about how the societal tensions are
impacting the us and the u.s economy
care to weigh in on that well for 200
years the way to solve for individuals
in an economy like the united states of
america is to grow the economy so that
it's for the benefit of everybody and
the best way to do that is to make the
american economy competitive and the way
you make it competitive is you make sure
that you don't charge more tax than your
competing country competitions of
nations really really matter and so the
concern i have and i share raised
concerns about divisiveness but the
package being proposed in addition to
the 1.2 trillion for infrastructure
another three and a half trillion of
just social spending makes no sense
because it will take the tax rate for
the united states from where it's in the
middle of the g20 right now right in the
middle the right place to be and take it
up to the top
right at the top the most highly taxed
country in the world for corporate taxes
but then in an addition which has never
been tried before which is really scary
if you want to worry about something no
country has ever taken itself to the top
of corporate taxes and made their
citizens in states like new york
massachusetts uh you know places like
california the highest taxed individuals
in the world they're paying the highest
taxes in the world individually and the
companies they work for pay the highest
corporate taxes that's never been done
that won't work that would cause
catastrophe so i'm happy that washington
is really fighting about this as they
should and if they get nothing done that
would be better than actually
bankrupting the american economy in a
way that would make it so uncompetitive
so let the games continue politicians
don't agree but remember most of these
politicians while i applaud their
leadership as politicians have never
actually run businesses and so the
people that actually create the jobs in
america don't want to be kicked to the
sidelines through uncompetitive policies
that's my two cents as a
business operator and owner
all right but say sanity does not
prevail and some version of this gets
passed there's also this idea of taxing
unrealized capital gains as well i mean
tax laws are being sort of turned upside
down now
if some version of this does pass
including that minimum global corporate
tax rate
what does that mean
well again you have to be pragmatic and
realistic about how this works these
outrageous ideas that are so fringe
whether they be french the right or
french to the left is because
politicians have to spend a third to
half their day raising money every
single day for their campaigns the the
only way they're going to get in front
of you and the rest of the media is to
say crazy stuff so you'll give them some
air time so that they can actually say
please send me some money so i can get
this crazy policy implemented and for
their constituents and right now the
democratic party is being held
primarily by very progressive and
left-wing ideas and biden has to you
know at least listen to them he's got to
try and keep his party together but i'm
very confident in the way that this
works that sound or middle-of-the-road
policies will actually be generated so i
don't think we're going to do things
that have already been tried in france
and england remember in england they had
tax rates of 92 percent in the 60s that
didn't work the french tried to tax you
know unrealized gains
in even more recent times that really
didn't work they they had a mass exodus
of capital the same thing would happen
here it just doesn't work and there's
lots of evidence that it won't and so
again you've got you have to respect
politicians fighting for every dollar
they can raise trying to get media
trying to do what they can on the social
platforms
you if you're just a rational
middle-of-the-road politician you get no
air time you got to be out on the fringe
and you got to say stuff that really
grabs clicks and that's one of the big
criticisms of social media these days
you make us some excellent points there
kevin i appreciate the overall optimism
before i let you go though i do want to
touch on gold because even powell is
saying that inflation
is not that transitory it's being seen
as more persistent than even he
initially expected now last time you
were on kitko you said you're still
keeping a five percent allocation to
gold is that still the case and how do
you break down that gold allocation if
it is
yes i have kept my five percent waiting
and i i pay for storage of gold bullion
have for years and then i also use
various etfs to balance every quarter
keeping it to five percent waiting
either buying in or selling it selling
down and so i've i've always considered
gold which has been around for 2000
years the romans hoarded it i always say
that i consider it a decent heads
against inflation i see no reason to
sell it i'm not going to transfer all of
it into crypto what i have done is
reduce my exposure to fixed income and
bought more crypto with that so that's
one asset class i'm not that excited
about right now because as you pointed
out we're starting to see a little push
on the 10 year and concerns about
inflation that's not transitory and uh
but also i would remind you going back
in history when you do get inflation
that gives corporate pricing power and
so you often have a situation where
you're getting inflation as long as it's
not runaway inflation and you have
corporations doing very very well in
stocks doing also doing well so i'm i'm
still very constructive on a 70
weighting in equities versus 30 percent
of fixed income and uh and creeping in
into those equities or some of those
companies that are involved in the
crypto and decentralized finance in my
holdings so i would say it's a very very
interesting time to be an investor and
there's lots of different opinions out
there and that's what makes a market and
that's why i love to be in the markets
if you like that video wait do you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe